so if you're working out with someone  and one person's stronger than the other  person the strong guy goes first and has  three plates on the bar the weaker guy  might go up and if he has an ego give it  a shot even though it's above his  strength level and even if he could pull  it off it'd be poor and it'd probably be  risky because he isn't stronger business  is a lot like that because entrepreneurs  will have the right strategy and lifting  heavier weight is not wrong and it's the  right way to get strong but it's just  who advanced for where you're at right  now and it takes humility like the guy  who says you know what I'm going to peel  a plate off because it's like I can do  that way better so that I can someday  level up and get strong enough to do  that more advanced thing it's not to say  that if you tried to build it you're  wrong for the idea is that you just  might not be there